(Music)
(Vocalizing)
Ndicela iyeza
lokuhlamba
ndisuse iinkathazo.
Ndicela iyeza
lokuhlamba
ndikhuphe iinkathazo.
(Vocalizing)
(Improvising)
Thongo lam vuma,
Thongo lam vuma.
Ndicela iyeza
lokuhlamba
ndisuse iinkathazo
ndicela iyeza
iyeza lokughabha
ndisuse iinkathazo
ndicela iyeza
lokuhlamba
ndisuse iinkathazo.
(Vocalizing)
Thongo lam vuma,
Lam vuma,
Lam vuma, lam vuma.
(Improvising)
(Music ends)
(Applause)
Thandiswa Mazwai: Hello everybody.
Thank you so much for having us here.
My name is Thandiswa Mazwai.
I am a wild woman,
a rebel singer, a conduit.
My music is about memory
and struggling between
oppresion and freedom.
After over 20 years in South Africa
we find ourselves as the black masses
still suffering and fighting
for our freedom and humanity.
This first song was called "Iyeza"
which means "medicine."
Medicine for our madness,
medicine for our rage.
This song we're doing now
is called "Zabalaza,"
and it means "rebel."
I'd like to dedicate this to the valiant
student movement in South Africa
who came up with the #FeesMustFall.
(Applause)
Rhodes Must Fall.
But more importantly,
the new vigor that has been brought
into the feminist movement
so patriarchy must fall.
(Applause)
(Music)
Gogo bek' umthwalo
Kunin' uhlupheka?
Little ghetto child
Ungazibulali sana
Oh ...
If you take my hand,
I'll show you
how to be free.
Ayifanelang' ub' iyenzeka lento
Emzini kabawo
kunge kudala
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
Sizozabalaza.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Vocalizing)
(Improvising)
It's my people in Soweto,
my people in Mozambique,
my people in Senegal.
These are my people in the ghettos.
Zabalaza, zabalaza.
Zabalaza.
(Music ends)
(Applause)
(Cheering)
Thank you very much.
(Applause)